hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president biden and gop congresswoman
liz cheney
both sharing warnings about a divided
republican party
suggesting lawmakers are at odds over
their support of former president trump
and election fraud claims florida
senator rick scott shares his thoughts
on the state of his party
big tech and the biden administration's
2.3 trillion dollar
infrastructure plan facebook's oversight
board
sparking a mix of reactions ruling to
uphold former president trump's
suspension
the move reigniting free speech debates
and calls for antitrust reforms
fox news sunday host chris wallace
discusses the board's ruling
and how social media companies influence
could impact the future of politics
plus commentary from fox nation host tom
chalu
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm jerry willis i'm steve ducey i'm
shannon bream and this
is the fox news rundown
friday may 7th 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal
republican slam president biden's plans
to tax and spend
but the president says the gop doesn't
even know what it stands for
they're not talking about who's gonna
you know be running the party they're
not talking about
who's going to be the president 24
they're talking about how do we
improve this country and how do we stop
the radical left
biden agenda we speak with florida
republican senator rick scott
i'm lisa brady are they stopping
violence or just stifling speech
the big tech debate heats up again as a
trump ban
continues there's no question that that
is mobilizing
opposition on the right to these
platforms
and the argument that they're censoring
conservative thought we speak with fox
news sunday host chris wallace
and i'm tom chalu i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
while many republicans are focused on
limiting the amount of spending
president biden wants to do
the president is accusing republicans of
not having their act together
it seems as though the republican party
is trying to identify what it stands for
and they're in the midst of a
significant
sort of mini-revolution going on the
republican party
there is some infighting house gop
conference chair wyoming congresswoman
liz chaney may lose her position
she's facing a lot of criticism over her
remarks about former president trump
writing recently that the gop is at a
turning point accusing many republicans
of following him with blind loyalty
not taking the capital riots seriously
enough and supporting the former
president's claims about election fraud
south carolina republican congresswoman
nancy mace was asked about the
infighting on america's newsroom the
american experiment is all about a
debate of ideas we should be able to
disagree
and not be attacked over it but in order
for us to win back the house in two
years
we must have a unified front both our
leadership and our conference as a whole
i sit in a swing district
i would like to keep that district and
go out and get a few more so we can get
a majority back so we can make changes
for the better
for better prosperity better freedom in
this country right now we've got to be
unified and that's my greatest
frustration with all of it the former
president himself weighed in on his own
platform
urging republican leadership to push
cheney out
so is the gop going through a mini
revolution
or is this normal post-election loss
introspection
you know jessica if you get out outside
of dc
you don't hear any of this florida
republican senator rick scott
and what they're focused on is jobs
better education
public safety and what they're
they're furious about is the biden
agenda they don't
they want to secure border they're
frustrated with what he's done on the
border he's clearly created a crisis
they want their schools open they don't
want men playing in women's sports
they don't want to shut down the
keystone pipeline they don't want to
shut down fossil fuels they want to
don't want to become energy independent
they're frustrated with all biden's
proposals basically to
radically change this country which
nobody voted for that
all these things they're doing so you
know you get you get outside dc
people in bed have any earthy idea what
you would be talking about if
uh because they're so focused on their
own personal lives
and how to improve their families that
said this conversation about the gop is
happening as you know article after
article really gets printed about um
this division among republicans namely
the idea that
um congresswoman liz chaney might lose
her position as conference chair in the
house
over her comments about president trump
and january 6th
my question for you is how big of a risk
is it for republicans ahead of 2022
to say that they're conservative but not
necessarily a fan of president trump's
just i talked to people all day all over
you know primarily in florida but all
over the country
this is not even a conversation they're
thinking about
their own families they're saying what
can we do to get this economy going
what can we do to make sure we have
options for our schools
what can we do to make sure we have a
safe community that's what they're
talking
that's what they're talking about
they're not talking about who's gonna
who's gonna
you know be running the party they're
not talking about who's gonna be the
president
24 they're talking about how do we
improve this country
and how do we stop the radical left
biden agenda that's what they're talking
about they're not talking about
anything's happening in dc
on that note president biden when he
talks about his plans to to spend
in trillions of dollars with what he
calls the american jobs act the american
family's plan
uh when he talks about it he says the
spending is necessary in large part to
compete with other countries namely
china
that you know autocracies can just spend
and decide and they don't have to reach
a consensus to do so
i assume you i assume you don't disagree
with that reasoning but you but
you do disagree with the the that
spending is the way to compete
look i i just just i grew up with an
american dream the american dream is
you start with nothing uh like i did and
lived in public housing not even knowing
my dad
and you get to go build something you
don't build something through government
doing things you don't
do something through government handouts
you do something because you come up
with a great idea
uh and you figure out how to build a
company that's that's the dream of this
country it's not government spending
the the if you look at what the biden
biden's doing right now
he's bankrupt in this country we're at
28 trillion dollars with that
with the last bill they passed which had
very little to do with covid they called
it a coveted bill
they'll take us to 30 trillion dollars
worth of debt the next two bills
their so-called infrastructure bill has
like six percents for road bridges
airports and seaports
um it's been basically very little more
than what i spent
uh on those things in my eight years as
governor for the whole country
uh so america doesn't want everything to
be free because you know what they know
if government gives you something one
they've got to pay for it through
somebody's taxes
and they're worried about it's going to
be theirs and number two they know that
if government gives you something
government sets all the rules they take
away all your all your freedom all your
liberties
to do things so when i travel
uh when i talk to people they're not
anxious for government to get bigger
bigger they're anxious for government to
get out of their lives so then get their
lives in order
i know republicans have introduced their
own infrastructure bill i think the
price tag was
close to 570 billion dollars what
happens here now like can some debate
happen on the president's proposal and
the republican proposal and is that
debate
happening happening now you know it's
just clearly up to the democrats you
know they they
didn't want to talk to us um with regard
to
uh their so-called covet bill they had a
little to do with kovid
so who knows what they're going to do
but what what i'm going to make sure
is we whatever we do it's going to be
for roads bridges airports and seaports
and it's going to be paid for
we cannot continue to run deficits after
deficit after deficit
there's a day of reckoning for you know
30 trillion dollars worth of debt
you can already look at inflation look
at what's happened to gas prices
since november you can look at food
prices you can look at the price for
household goods
you know so you could you can see what's
going on inflation is
happening people are getting very
concerned and who hurt who
inflation hurts the most is the poor and
those on fixed income
americans are very concerned about
inflation divided administration
you know and jay pal the federal reserve
wants to act like oh
nothing you know spending to oblivion
um borrowing money forever and there's
never any consequence
uh they think we'll never see inflation
so if
you know history repeats itself you
cannot go waste money like this
and by the way when biden says he's only
gonna tax and people make it over four
hundred thousand dollars first
he's already taxed he's already passed
the tax increase under the so-called
coveted bill
for uber drivers door dash people like
that and
there's not the the people make over 400
000 a year don't make enough money
to pay for all these these programs
that biden wants to do i mean there's
there's not there's not enough money
he needs to be honest with the american
public that he's trying to create a
socialist society
which america does not want we are a
capless society
we want free markets we want to make our
own choices we don't need government to
run our lives
i have a question about maybe something
republicans and democrats might agree on
i i earlier this week heard senator
martin heinrich of new mexico at an
intel event
he was praising the company for
investing billions to increase their
manufacturing here in the u.s
and he said on the goal of manufacturing
computer processing in the us he has
never
seen such bipartisanship in congress in
his career
is that your sense as well that there
are some
issues that you that republicans and the
democrats can agree on maybe
supply chain issues manufacturing more
here at home especially if it comes to
tech
i think we all agree that communist
china has clearly decided to become
our adversary they want to dominate the
world they want to build the military
smart
are bigger than ours and and we've got
to do everything we can to buy american
where we disagree on is we is where
there's going to be through centralized
planning
if you and me i am i completely oppose
the federal government trying to decide
how to run this country how to run the
manufacturing
uh portion of our economy the free
market works we all need to
stop buying things made in china start
buying things made in america
but we don't need the federal government
to run the policy and by the way
when they do that it always impact
always means
bigger government more money out of your
pocket your taxes
every every program they have we have to
all remember it comes out of your pocket
you are going to pay higher taxes for
everything they do
senator speaking of free market let's
talk about
big tech and social media companies
because you've introduced some
legislation that would address
data privacy and algorithms but some of
your colleagues are introducing
legislation
that you know some could argue is not so
free market it has to do with like
breaking up big tech anti-trust um
talk to me about uh the importance in
your mind of data privacy
how your proposed legislation differs
say from california's data privacy law
or europe's gdpr and and secondly you
know
do you support the legislation that some
of your colleagues are introducing
having to do with like antitrust
and big tech and social media
well big tech is um you know it
acts like they can control everything
they want to censor conservatives
but they want to give brutal dictators
like the ayatollah and maduro free pass
uh they you know they want to gather
manipulate sell our
our personal data with no consequences
so
i believe they have to be held
accountable we can all argue
about how they should be held
accountable but in my case i want to
protect the rights of american citizens
i introduce the data act it's going to
give us americans we're going to say
what happens with
our personal information and there's
going to be recourse if these
these you know big tech companies
violate our privacy
we should be making decisions what you
do with our data we should be making
decisions
if you're going to go try to sell our
personal have information about our
personal habits
you don't have a right to that so that's
where i want to hold
a big tech accountable but when they go
out and they act like
no they they can control everything they
can censor some people let other people
talk
they're going to get held accountable
americans are fed up
with big tech taking their data with no
consequences
and censoring certain people not others
are you
supportive of maybe some of the other
legislation though too like
if something results in breaking up the
companies
well i look i i'm we're talk there's a
lot of conversations about what
what we should do what what my biggest
focus right now is
is is making sure they don't they don't
can't control our own personal
information
but the reason why we're having this
conversation
is that big tech is acting like they're
acting like monopoly
and in in this country monopolies do get
regulated
and so they're doing it to themselves i
have one last question for you
charlie crist former governor of florida
says he will run for governor again
against ron desantis
um my understanding if i recall he's a
former republican governor but he's
running as a democrat now
i believe he lost to you in the
governor's race in 2014.
i'm wondering based on some of the
polling data we've been looking at and i
know
polling data i know but based on some of
it
does he have a shot it sounds like a new
pull out this week
has uh desantis just five points ahead
of
of crist well
first off charlie's got to figure out
what party's in
uh that's number one number two is as
people understand what charlie did in
his four years
or home prices dropped in half we lost
800 000 jobs
um he raised taxes as people go back and
and you know go back and review his
record i think he'll have a very
difficult
time winning any race
senator rick scott thank you so much for
your time
all right thanks jessica have a great
[Music]
day
this is tom chalu with your fox news
commentary coming up
this week's ruling by the facebook
oversight board upholding a ban on
former president donald trump
but also calling the punishment
arbitrary is rekindling the debate
over the power of social media companies
who they're silencing
and what they're blocking the
president's view is that
the major platforms have a
responsibility
related to the health and safety of all
americans to stop
amplifying untrustworthy content
especially says white house spokeswoman
jensaki
disinformation and misinformation on
vaccines and elections
but republicans say there's a political
bias louisiana senator john kennedy
telling fox news
no one believes that the social media
platforms
will regulate or censor let's say
senator bernie sanders like they would
former president donald trump facebook
says it believes the trump ban was
necessary and right
after the capital riot the oversight
board says the company
can't just make up penalties as it goes
along though giving it a deadline to
come up with a better plan
mark zuckerberg and facebook clearly
wanted this
semi-independent i say semi-independent
because they appointed them
board to settle this for them so they
could say well it was the board that
decided chris wallace is the host of fox
news sunday
and what the board ended up deciding was
uh look you can keep the ban for six
months you
basically don't have any rules this
seems to have been a completely ad hoc
decision so you you've got six months to
come up with your own
policy your own plan and your own
decision as to what you're going to do
to donald trump
and you know they're not saying you can
you can re they're saying you can
reinstate them you can ban
them but you have to have a policy in
place here so
basically the oversight board uh took
the hot potato and threw it right back
to facebook and mark zuckerberg and said
no
you handle it of course the former
president didn't waste
any time slamming not just facebook but
twitter and
google which owns youtube the bottom
line is though he's still not on
those platforms do you think he can be
as effective with the new platform that
his
former campaign manager created no
but this from the desk of it's a website
you know i mean i had to laugh at their
talk about well this is a new social
media platform it's a website
um and a website is incidentally as you
say
the website is banned by a lot of these
other platforms
he was able to use the megaphone of
facebook
and and reach 100 million people and
facebook and facebook
uh and you know and twitter and and he
doesn't have that right now now maybe
it'll change but
you know that's this is not my area of
strengths given that i'm not on either
twitter or facebook
but i'm told by a lot of people who knew
more than i do that it would really be
hard for him
to successfully run for election in 2024
both in terms of getting his message out
and also in terms of raising money
without access to those platforms so
you know this is not just a question of
his ability
to to talk and to and to use the
megaphone
it's it may raise real practical
questions
about his ability to run for president
and that raises questions of course
about
can or or should a media platform
like facebook be able to in effect
is a practical matter block somebody
from running for election
well and then it gets into this larger
debate too that conservatives are
trying to say that they're being
targeted by these platforms and it's a
debate that's overlapping with
republican leadership struggles now too
congressman liz chaney was staring down
a second no confidence vote with
congressman elise
congresswoman elise stefanik building
support to replace her
well then twitter suspended the account
of stefanik's communications chief
do these companies think that people
want them to draw
red lines like election fraud as a
blacklisted topic
or are they digging a hole for
themselves
well uh you know i think that both are
true
that they they do want the the clearly
and and particularly you know we do have
to say january 6th happen the
insurrection of the capital happened
this isn't just
simply an intellectual exercise on the
part of these
social media platforms they they have
every reason to believe that the
the big lie and that's what it was that
uh
that the election was stolen from donald
trump uh
that that the spreading of that message
on their platforms contributed
to the insurrection of the capital and
the violence of the capital
so i can understand on the one hand
their concern about not wanting
to give cover to you know one of the
things they do say is
they don't want to propagate any speech
which incites violence on the other hand
that there's no question
that that is mobilizing opposition
on the right to these platforms and the
argument that they're censoring
conservative thought
congresswoman cheney wrote an op-ed
urging republicans
as she put it to stand for genuinely
conservative principles
and steer away from the quote dangerous
and anti-democratic trump
cult of personality is that the crux
of what's facing the republican party
well no i don't think so and and and
you know i i think you have to look at
this these
these weeks since january 6 and what liz
cheney has said and done
uh in in context as a narrative to
understand what the
part the the objection of republicans
remember when she first came out and
voted for impeachment and first took on
uh donald trump there was a test vote
as to whether to oust her in the
republican caucus in the house
and she won overwhelmingly almost three
to one but
because at that point people weren't
willing to say hey if you oppose donald
trump
you can't be a leader in the party i
think the issue
is more that she has continued to talk
about that as opposed to other people
who voted for impeachment
who just stopped stopped talking about
you know they made their point
and they moved on to pursue a lot of
other issues
and and i think it's fair to say that
liz cheney and you
i'm not saying she's right or wrong to
do this but she continued to pick the
scab off the open wound of donald trump
and what he did about the election in
january 6.
and if you're a republican member of
congress and you want to take back the
house
in 2022 and you want to have kevin
mccarthy as the speaker
when you've got a majority of
republicans saying they still support
donald trump and i think the majority
still believe that the election was
stolen
is that a fight you want to pick so so i
can understand
a republican who maybe doesn't even even
have that much sympathy or support
for donald trump saying i don't want the
number three leader in the house
to be constantly making this argument
and constantly alienate not just donald
trump
forget about him but the millions of
people who support donald trump it isn't
uh it isn't a
formula for success in the 2022 midterms
president biden continues to make the
case that his
spending proposals are necessary they're
worth it
in the in the grand scheme of things is
that gaining
any traction with the american public
well
it's it's apparently pretty popular the
more interesting subject to me lisa
is that he made a couple of statements
this week that he really is
interested in a bipartisan compromise
i'm not sure whether that's true or not
but you know the rubber is going to hit
the road here this next week he's going
to be meeting with mcconnell and
mccarthy
and pelosi and schumer the four
congressional leaders for the first time
since he became president
and you know there is a compromise to be
made at a smaller number considerably
smaller number he wants 2.3 trillion
i think republicans would probably go
for seven or eight
hundred billion which is an enormous
amount of money but in washington's uh
washington terms today it's pocket
change and and if you were willing to
settle for that
and and frankly you get all the hardcore
infrastructure for that you don't get
the 400 billion dollars for elderly care
or disabled care but you do get
roads bridges highways airports water
services broadband if you were willing
to settle for that my guess is you could
get a deal made
um i think it's awfully interesting to
see whether or not he's willing to do
that i i think there are
very strong arguments for you know you
don't get everything you ask for
but it's good for the country to get
something with
bipartisan buy-in to show that
republicans democrats can legislate can
agree
can't pass something and you know 800
billion dollars in in infrastructures a
whole lot of money
he and other national leaders
are being accused yet again of some
mixed
messaging on masks because of what
they're doing or
not doing and maybe you know sending the
wrong message like
they're talking about if you're fully
vaccinated you can do more you don't
need a mask outside
um but then he still wears one
most of the time is that a problem is
that
is that making it harder for the country
to kind of get on with things
yeah absolutely i mean there's no
question about it because
i mean i know my my first reaction i'm
fully vaccinated
uh and and i i race to get vaccinated i
mean i
you know signed up like i think a lot of
people did with a half a dozen
websites to try to get vaccinated and
got as quickly as i could my wife has as
well
and you know my first reaction was a
tremendous sense of relief this is the
get out of jail free card
and then you found well you really can't
change your life you still have to wear
a mask and you still have to
socially distance and there are
questions as to how close you can get to
your grandkids
it seems to me one of the strongest
incentives to get people the biggest
issue right now it seems to me isn't
the mixed messages over masking it's the
reluctance of people to get the vaccine
you know we were up at four
million people a day now we're down to a
million
a day and we're not going to get uh you
know the kind of widespread
uh immunity with at a million a day
so so it seems to me to the degree that
you say to people and
not just you know an official on the
camera on tv
but people looking in their daily lives
that you say if you get vaccinated
you get to do things that you safely
that you couldn't do before
to me that's the best message there is
out there that
well get vaccinated because the sooner
you're vaccinated the sooner you get
back to normal and to the degree that
we're saying you get vaccinated but then
you still
can't be back to normal that's a
disincentive to get the shot
chris wallace host of fox news sunday
yes say who we got this week yes please
do
i'm very excited one of the co-chairs of
the uh
facebook oversight board former federal
judge
uh michael mcconnell and we're going to
talk to them about the decision they
made and the issues of free speech and
political censorship all of that and
then we're going to be talking jim banks
the head of the republican uh study
committee he's one of the top
republicans and he was one of the people
pushing for the ouster
of uh of liz cheney so both of those
stories on fox news sunday
oh i can't wait 2 p.m on fox news
channel
do not miss it chris wallace always a
pleasure thank you so much
thank you lisa my pleasure
[Music]
hey it's brett larsen inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily
fox on tech podcast there's part of a
colorful late 90s imac on mars
it's an idea that seems a lot like
kickstarter called build it subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your podcasts
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
a florida sheriff's office has received
a donation for its fallen officers fund
from an unlikely source deputy kevin
baker is with the hillsborough county
florida sheriff's office and in
mid-february he pulled over a driver for
going 15 miles an hour over the speed
limit
but instead of giving the person behind
the wheel a ticket he let her off with a
warning
in april deputy baker got a thank you
card from the driver with a check for
253 dollars
the same amount the ticket would have
been the driver said she was sending the
money as a donation for memorial fund
for fallen officer michael magley
who died in february while trying to
stop a suspected drunk driver
in a facebook post the hillsborough
sheriff's department thanked the driver
for the donation with the message
quote a hero remembered never dies
tanya j powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
tom chalu
what's on your mind hey mom it's me
tom happy mother's day happy mother's
day
look i know i could give you a call but
isn't this kind of cool
using the fox news rundown to say happy
mother's day
come on tell me who among your children
or your grandchildren
can say they wished you happy mother's
day
via a podcast huh
okay all right i'll admit it i forgot to
send a card so
if i'm the only one of your kids who
forgot to send a card
maybe this will make up for it maybe
while i'm at it there's a lot of other
mothers out there listening so happy
mother's day to all of you
and mom don't worry i will give you a
call too
okay my work is done wait a minute
my wife is a mom two if i forget her
card she won't be as kind
as mom and she won't fall for the
podcast routine either
all right i gotta go buy some flowers
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
new from the fox news podcast network my
name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes